Paramount Pictures says it plans to
partner with Leonardo DiCaprio's
production company to make a film about
Volkswagens of problems is acquired the
movie rights to the to a book about the
scandal the book actually hasn't even I
don't think been written yet it's a
puzzle right it's a book proposal and
yet they have the rights to do it I
don't know I mean do you want to see a
movie about someone like trying to fix
some wires or at a computer screen I
don't know if I want to see that some
very suspenseful typing at a computer
screen yeah certainly I mean there's
been this big trend towards biz pics in
the in Hollywood whether it's on the
small screen or on the big screen marky
mark is going to be in a movie about the
Deep Horizon the horizon well-oiled yes
exactly so that's a big one of course
the big short written by michael lewis
is going to be made into a movie as well
because all his movies all his books
have turned into really pretty
successful movies okay sure so he has a
track record you also the BP you know
oil spill which has a huge thing that
blew up and oil leaking out and like
birds covered in a special Marisol
Flores definitely like some good visuals
to go there but if you look at say the
too-big-to-fail movies that went on
there was one with me more that did that
I saw that did wasn't really great we
also have one on HBO I didn't hear a ton
of awesome things about meeting that
like it's not necessarily very visual
and compelling to do a finance story in
movies and it's easy to confuse people
as well I mean if you're talking about a
movie you've got to make it available
for mass consumption for TV you can
speak to a more fragmented audience a
more fractured audience Wall Street guys
we always look at these movies in st.
wait they didn't go in depth a lot they
didn't capture the real drama or the
real tension and everyone else will be
like what CBS is what appears I guess
what well the question is who is going
to play Martin Winterkorn who you have
to imagine will be like the evil villain
Darth Vader Fassbender by is my vote
leonhardt DiCaprio why do you else do
you think he wants you may not
necessarily be starring in the movie
it's just his production company that
has acquired the rights no stars no
directors have been attached to you can
have an accent they like accent with the
oscars at a note we'll see as long as he
doesn't gain weight cuz that's not a
good look